muy buenas tardes a todos
quiero decirles que la situación
climática nada tiene que ver con el
clima
todas las iniciativas de éxito analizan
la situación climática como un resultado
de la pobre o nula educación ambiental
que poseemos
vivimos
en un país donde acostumbramos a tratar
problemas puntuales
muchas veces olvidándonos de las causas
que realmente lo provocan
en ese mismísimo planeta tenemos allí
hay una isla llamada a la española o
quisqueya
yo tuve la suerte de nacer en república
dominicana una de las dos grandes
naciones que le han dado su identidad de
una presencia ante el mundo
desde muy pequeño me maravillé siempre
con nuestros viajes con mis padres al
campo a las montañas a las playas a los
bosques siempre me maravillaba a todos
los recursos increíbles que tiene
república dominicana
pero con el tiempo con los años
esa emoción ha ido pasando a decepción
ya que
a los lugares que visitó me maravillo de
la gran contaminación que existe en las
calles la quema de basura indiscriminada
en vertederos sin ningún tipo de control
y también la quema y acumulación de
basura en barrios marginales
por haber nacido en una isla pequeña y
ser catalogados como un país del tercer
mundo muchas veces nos condicionamos al
tomar algún tipo de acción y es por eso
que antes de empezar
muchas veces nos rendimos
sin embargo la historia nos muestra
constantemente
qué son las minorías lo que nos traen
las más importantes selecciones de vida
dice eduardo galeano
qué gente pequeña
en lugares pequeños
haciendo cosas pequeñas podrían cambiar
el mundo
sin embargo esto les falta un pequeñito
pero sumamente importante detalle el
cual es el liderazgo
aplicando liderazgo a esta frase que
acabamos de ver podemos ver que gente
imprescindible haciendo las cosas
primordiales en los lugares claves
transformarán el mundo
de esta forma fue que nació
los guardianes de el planeta proyecto
comunitario que junto a un grupo de
líderes el año pasado tuve la suerte de
desarrollar la forma de mini campamentos
ecológicos para las principales escuelas
de bávaro macao y punta cana
nuestra meta principal es crear líderes
estudiantiles que puedan ser entes de
cambio en las comunidades
nuestra estrategia ha sido visitar
lugares de suma importancia para tener
una métrica real y poder conocer cuáles
son los puntos más críticos de
contaminación en la zona de bávaro macao
y puntacana y que así de esta forma
apoyándonos en empresas que desarrollan
y practican políticas de sostenibilidad
y responsabilidad corporativa poder
traer un contenido actual y poder traer
una información valiosa a estos mini
campamentos y a nuestros estudiantes
visitamos lugares como el vertedero de
macao una montaña de basura de
aproximadamente 60 kilómetros cuadrados
donde cada día llega a 600 toneladas de
desechos y basura indiscriminadamente
a veces en su punto más alto las
montañas alcanzan hasta 14 pies de
altura
aquí en el vertedero viven
aproximadamente 100 familias de las
cuales quienes subsisten de la basura de
allí obtienen comida agua ropa y
cualquier cosa que puedan vender para
mantenerse
también pudimos visitar
el centro de reciclaje incineración
ubicado en el aeropuerto de punta cana
así también como las plantas de
recolección y reciclaje por servicios
dominicana las cuales captan la mayor
cantidad de desechos de punta
cana-bávaro parte de macao y verón
a través
de iniciativas como esta apoyándonos
también en la fundación del futurismo
responsable y el proyecto comunitario
proyecto tortuga hemos podido brindarle
a nuestros estudiantes y también todo el
público que así lo desee iniciativas
proyectos y actividades de
sostenibilidad
actividades ecológicas regulares como
son el saneamiento de comunidades focos
de contaminación y limpiezas de playas
ya en las escuelas por un espacio de
cuatro horas tuvimos la oportunidad de
conversar con líderes comunitarios con
representantes de entidades
medioambientales donde a través de
talleres dinámicas grupo trabajos en
grupo todos los estudiantes pudieron
presentar sus propuestas
de soluciones innovadoras tanto para
problemas que ocurren en sus comunidades
así también como problemas que afectan a
toda la nación de los resultados más
importantes puedo mencionar que en un
centro se eliminó la compra de botellas
de agua embotellada y con ese dinero
pudieron comprar
bebederos refrigerados de agua potable
para todos los estudiantes en un centro
también de horario extendido la comida
que sobraba en vez de votarse se pudo
destinar para alimentar hasta 80
animales en situación de calle cercanos
al centro educativo también dos grupos
educan estudiantiles se juntaron para
generar la limpieza de las playas de
macao y de los corales también creando
micro charlas para los turistas y los
locales que se encontraban allí sobre la
limpieza en la importancia de mantener
nuestros recursos
acá también pueden ver parte de la labor
del proyecto tortuga quienes de una
forma estratégica han colocado
contenedores para captar botellas
plásticas también actividades como arte
con reciclaje y actividades para los más
pequeños también
ya en la parte económica llevar a cabo
estos campamentos
para el por cada 100 estudiantes
significa una inversión de 200 mil pesos
tuvimos la suerte de poder contar con
empresas que dedican capital para
invertir en este tipo de iniciativas
y pudimos cubrir el 100 por ciento de
nuestros gastos este año
y queremos llevar los campamentos a
santiago de los caballeros y con la
propuesta que hemos creado queremos
tocar todo el país para el 2025
dice greta convert creadora de el
movimiento fire for future que nadie es
tan pequeño para que pueda liderar un
cambio un impacto que cambie el mundo se
creativo y us cuanto puedas
esa es nuestra meta de poder alcanzar
todos los centros educativos para el
2025 y poder de cierta forma cambiar la
perspectiva que tienen nuestros
estudiantes sobre su impacto ambiental y
poder accesar ese potencial que se
encuentra dormido en ellos y que se
encuentra latente en todos nosotros
esperando que la próxima persona nos
pregunte qué vas a hacer diferente a
partir de ahora a que te comprometes a
ser diferente
gente imprescindible haciendo las cosas
primordiales en los lugares clave
cambiarán al mundo transformarán al
mundo
la educación ambiental la transformación
en la educación en nuestras escuelas más
que una necesidad es una
responsabilidad principal que todos
debemos asumir para y por el futuro de
nuestros jóvenes y de nuestros
estudiantes que se van a convertir en la
fuerza empresarial que va a llevar la
república dominicana a estar de cara al
futuro en las nuevas políticas y
prácticas medioambientales
entonces quiero que vayan hoy a casa con
actitud de líderes con una actitud
responsable siempre preguntándonos a qué
me comprometo a ser diferente hoy que se
vayan visualizando como cada día esos
estudiantes que pudieron participar en
nuestros campamentos se levantan cada
mañana con un nuevo protector y un ojo
vigilante de sus comunidades de sus
escuelas y sobre todo de su país
muchas gracias y buenas noches
[Aplausos]